nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
on part aux États-Unis pour parler
découpage électorale là-bas on dit avec
humour que ce ne sont pas les électeurs
qui choisissent leur politiciens mais
les politiciens qui choisissent leurs
électeurs et c'est un peu vrai tous les
10 ans après chaque recensement dans
chacun des 50 États américains le parti
au pouvoir peut redessiner les cartes
électorales et pour s'assurer de
remporter les élections suivantes et
bien le parti en question souvent
découpe les districts à son avantage
Fanny Allard bonjour vous êtes notre
correspondante aux États-Unis vous êtes
intéressé à ce qu'on appelle en France
la tambouille électorale là-bas ça a un
autre nom
oui alors ici ça s'appelle le Jerry
mandring et Jerry mandering comme vous
l'avez dit Antoine c'est tout simplement
le découpage partisan des
circonscriptions électorales dans le but
de donner l'avantage à un parti plutôt
qu'à un autre en l'occurrence ici aux
États-Unis soit au parti républicains
soit au parti démocrates le terme de
Jerry mandring est né au 19e siècle
juste avant l'élection présidentielle de
1811 lorsque le gouverneur du
Massachusetts qui s'appelait helbridge
Jerry fut accusé d'avoir découpé la
circonscription d'un comté pour
favoriser son parti ça avait alors créé
une polémique et les journaux avaient
publié une caricature représentant
ladite circonscription sous la forme
d'une salamandre qui se dit Salamander
en anglais Jerry mandering est donc un
mot valise composé de Jerry du nom du
gouverneur et de mendeur qui vient donc
de Salamander salamandre en français
cela nous dit une chose c'est que cette
pratique bien peu démocratique a lieu
depuis maintenant deux siècles comme
c'est le cas en noyau mais je vous
laisse le découvrir dans ce reportage
alors on regarde effectivement ce sujet
que vous avez consacré à ces manœuvres
politiciennes dans démocratie en danger
reportage de Fanny Allard pour France 24
et on vous retrouve juste après
[Musique]
ici c'est l'un des plus pauvres et des
plus petits comté de l'Ohio
[Musique]
état du nord-est des États-Unis compte
près de 12 millions d'habitants
54% sont républicains 46% démocrates
pourtant au terme des scrutants on
trouve une sur-représentation des lus
républicains
sont trafiquées nous savons à l'avance
qui va gagner c'est ce qui vient de se
passer en noyau et les électeurs ne
peuvent pas faire grand-chose nous avons
des élections tous les deux ans alors
ils pensent qu'ils participent mais les
résultats sont joués d'avance c'est un
système malade
ce système malade David Pepper en a fait
son combat cet ancien président du parti
démocrate de l'Ohio dénonce la pratique
du Jerry mandering
le Jerry mandering une pratique presque
aussi vieille que la démocratie
américaine et qui vise à redécouper les
circonscriptions pour favoriser le parti
au pouvoir pour comprendre ce phénomène
il nous emmène dans le village de
Manchester
une ville qui existe depuis plus d'un
siècle et voilà à quoi ça ressemble les
élus à Columbus prennent l'argent des
villes comme celle-ci pour raccorder des
réductions d'impôts aux gens très riches
au lieu d'investir dans ce qui
permettrait de relancer ses villes ces
démons
depuis 10 ans le Parlement de Loyau a
réduit le budget destiné aux dépenses
locales d'un milliard de dollars par an
ce qui a pénalisé tous les secteurs
publics écoles police santé et
infrastructures
à quoi ressemblait la ville il y a 40
ans est-ce que tous ces bâtiments
étaient occupés
oui
et
là il y avait un pressing
à Manchester les coupes budgétaires se
sont ajoutées à la fermeture en 2018 de
la centrale à charbon depuis les élus
n'ont voté aucun investissement majeur
pour la communauté
cette ville nous dit beaucoup sur l'état
de la démocratie car il y a quelques
années ses habitants ont contacté leur
sénateurs et demander de l'aide pour
lutter contre les délitements de la
ville
et bien après les avoir écoutés le
sénateur leur a répondu que parfois la
seule solution est de déménager tout est
dit les circonscriptions ici sont
toujours truquées donc les politiciens
sont assurés d'être réélu quoi qu'il
arrive
autrement dit peu importe leur bilan les
élus ne craignent pas la sanction des
urnes
si ça se passait dans un autre pays nous
considérerions que la démocratie est
attaquée mais comme on est en Amérique
et qu'on est fier de notre démocratie on
ne s'en rend pas compte
à Washington le découpage partisan des
circonscriptions est une pratique bien
connue oui les députés des sénateurs
républicains depuis 40 ans pour lui la
pratique du Jerry mandring est
constitutive de la politique américaine
le Jerry mandaring existe depuis que
nous avons une république
constitutionnelle
ce n'est pas l'apanage d'un parti plus
que d'un autre si les démocrates sont
frustrées dans l'Ohio c'est parce que
les républicains sont au pouvoir mais je
vous garantis que si vous allez dans
l'État de New York en Californie ou dans
l'Illinois où ce sont les démocrates qui
sont au pouvoir vous trouverez alors des
républicains mécontents
dans chaque État les circonscriptions
sont redessinées tous les 10 ans après
le recensement national
se redécoupage territorial permet au
parti majoritaire de choisir ses
électeurs selon des critères sociaux
religieux et même ratio mais si le Jerry
mandring est bien pratiqué par les deux
parties en 2010 les républicains ont
initié le projet redmap qui leur a
permis de gagner un maximum de
législature
en 2010 les républicains ont consacré
beaucoup de moyens financiers pour faire
élire leur candidats dans les parlements
des États car ce sont les législateurs
des États qui dessinent les cartes
et comme ce projet a réussi les
républicains ont l'avantage aujourd'hui
et depuis 10 ans dans le découpage des
circonscriptions
c'est pour cela qu'il y a plus de
républicains qui font du Jerry mandarin
un avantage d'autant plus important
qu'en 2010 les républicains ont
bénéficié d'outils numériques nouveaux
leur permettant de cibler les électeurs
comme jamais auparavant Jane Miller
dirige la Ligue des électrices de l'Ohio
qui se bat contre le Gerry mandandering
vous voyez s'il y a toutes ces formules
bizarres c'est parce que les
cartographes ont pu utiliser des
technologies avancées pour comprendre
les intentions de votre des électeurs à
l'intérieur des ménages
et donc il coupe tranche et décompose
les compter les communautés et les
villes pour sécuriser une majorité
républicaine qui n'existerait pas
autrement
par exemple Cincinnati aurait dû être un
bloc mais ils l'ont coupé en deux pour
diluer les voies des démocrates
ce genre de forme montre qu'ils ont
essayé de choisir foyer par foyer et
lecteur par électeurs qui votent dans
quel district la Ligue des électrices de
l'Ohio a déposé deux plaintes en 2021
contestant les cartes électorales du
Parlement de l'État la Cour suprême
noyau à statué en leur faveur en jugeant
ses cartes anticonstitutionnelles mais
trop tard pour faire exécuter le
jugement les dernières élections de
mi-mandat ont donc eu lieu sur la base
de cartes donnant à nouveau une super
majorité aux républicain voilà les
résultats du 8 novembre
à la Chambre 64 sièges contre 35
au Sénat 25 sièges contre 8
le Sénat est encore pire qu'avant
malgré le fait que la Cour suprême de
l'Ohio est jugée ses cartes
inconstitutionnelle on est aujourd'hui
dans une situation où les citoyens se
retrouvent avec encore plus de
redécoupage partisans au Parlement
on se focalise souvent sur le Congrès
des États-Unis parce que c'est là que
sont décidés les lois fédérales mais ici
dans l'Ohio le Parlement statut sur des
lois qui concerne l'accès au vote
l'avortement et les droits des jeunes
LGBTQ ces décisions dépendent de la
Chambre et du Sénat de l'Ohio et ont
donc un impact direct sur la vie de ses
habitants
[Musique]
les jeunes transgenres sont justement la
cible de plusieurs propositions de loi
visant à limiter leurs droits l'une
d'elles veut t'empêcher les filles
transgenres de jouer dans des équipes de
sport féminines à l'école à 17 ans Amber
a été la première transgenreau a joué au
softballa
ce sont les uniformes de mon équipe
d'été on mélange les couleurs
moi j'aime bien le vert et le noir
ensemble
au moment de la puberté Amber n'a pas
supporté la mue de sa voix elle a alors
arrêté de parler pendant deux ans mais à
trouver refuge dans ce sport
j'adore ça
m'a permis de trouver une communauté
un environnement sécurisant
je me suis fait des amis ça m'a donné
confiance en moi
avant de pouvoir intégrer son équipe
Amber a dû se soumettre à une multitude
de tests pour prouver qu'elle n'avait
pas de capacité physique supérieur aux
autres filles
imaginez être banni de son équipe la met
donc en colère
[Musique]
la plupart d'entre nous ne veulent pas
qu'il soit élu et pourtant ils finissent
toujours par gagner
c'est à cause du découpage électoral
truqué
nos voix ne sont pas comptés comme elles
le devraient pour une représentation
juste de la population de l'Ohio dans
son ensemble
depuis 2015 seul 13 filles transgenres
font partie des types de sport au
collège ou au lycée dans l'Ohio la loi
ne concernerait donc qu'une poignée
d'individus sur des centaines de
milliers d'élèves pour la mère d'Amber
c'est la conséquence directe d'une
politique d'extrême droite
actuellement dans notre pays il y a une
vraie volonté des organisations
chrétiennes conservatrices de pousser
pour faire passer des lois en titre
transgenres ça me met hors de moi de
savoir que mes impôts payent une
législation qui pratique la
discrimination légale et que je ne suis
même pas un tout petit peu représenté
le député et le sénateur de notre
district
soutiennent tous les deux ces lois
et mon député ne veut même pas me
recevoir malgré mes appels
Amber a voté pour la première fois cette
année aux élections de mi-mandat et vous
n'avez même si ça semble inutile nous
devons absolument voter autrement nous
baissons les bras
[Musique]
ne pas baisser les bras c'est exactement
ce qu'a fait émicocx
cette candidate démocrate à la chambre
de l'Ohio s'est présentée dans une
circonscription où elle savait qu'elle
n'avait aucune chance de gagner mais
pour cette ancienne institutrice
l'important est de proposer une
alternative
je ne cherche pas à gagner cette
circonscription parce que je ne peux pas
la gagner c'est impossible elle a été
dessinée pour mon adversaire j'ai fait
campagne pour informer les électeurs sur
les législatives de l'État
près de 119 000 personnes vivent dans la
circonscription que visiter mis mais
seul un tiers a voté le 8 novembre
ici c'est une voisine elle est
républicaine mais elle me connaît et
elle me soutient
ici ce sont aussi des républicains je
n'essaye même pas parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas parler politique avec moi
Emy a perdu avec 28% des voix contre 72
pour son adversaire républicain ce
jour-là elle retourne voir les électeurs
de sa circonscription
bonjour Rémy bonjour Comment ça va bien
et toi je voulais savoir si tu étais
satisfait des résultats de l'élection
on en a déjà parlé dans notre comté
malheureusement
c'est comme s'il n'y avait qu'un parti
et j'ai beau être républicain je vote
pour la personne que je juge compétente
pas seulement pour une étiquette
le Parti démocrate de l'Ohio est
seulement les candidats ayant une chance
de gagner rafinancer leur campagne c'est
pour pallier cela que David Pepper a
créé l'organisation blue oohio Ohio bleu
la couleur politique des démocrates si
nous parvenons à avoir des milliers
d'adhérents alors chaque candidat
potentiel dans l'Ohio saura que nous
sommes là pour le soutenir
uniquement avec 200 dollars cette fois
c'était autour de 5000 dollars et dans
quelques années ça pourrait être 10 ou
12000 dollars
blue Ayou a démarré il y a 6 mois et
compte déjà 1100 membres l'objectif pour
David Pepper et de rendre le pouvoir aux
électeurs
ne se présente ils ne veulent même pas
que les électeurs aient le choix niquent
leurs candidat est à rendre des comptes
c'est pour cela que nous avons lancé
blue Ohio pour encourager des candidats
à se présenter même si c'est difficile
et nous sommes fiers d'avoir soutenu ces
candidats
parce que s'il ne se présente pas ça
laisse au républicains le monopole et
c'est ce qui mène à l'extrémisme
[Musique]
l'avortement les droits des transgenres
ou encore l'accès au bureau de vote sont
aujourd'hui menacés dans 23 États
alors que les yeux sont souvent rivés
sur Washington les droits fondamentaux
des Américains
se joue en réalité
à l'échelon local
et on retrouve Fanny Allard notre
correspondante aux États-Unis Fanny
cette démocratie américaine qui série
Jean modèle universel et donc loin
d'être irréprochable qui en souffre le
plus
bien concrètement tous les Américains
dès lors que les circonscriptions sont
dessinés selon des calculs partisans
avec en plus aujourd'hui des outils
numériques redoutables d'études des
ménages la plupart des électeurs de
l'opposition aux parties en place que ce
soit les républicains dans l'Ohio ou les
démocrates dans le Maryland considèrent
légitimement que leur vote ne compte pas
on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans le reportage
avec Amber et sa mère mais pour être
tout à fait précise je dirais que les
communautés de couleurs souffrent tout
particulièrement du ji-mandering
notamment dans les états du sud des
États-Unis même si évidemment redécouper
les cartes selon des critères ratiaux et
interdits dans les faits il y a une
corrélation évidemment entre les
origines sociales le lieu de résidence
et l'orientation politique et comme il y
a toujours eu une forme de ségrégation
résidentielle aux États-Unis un peu
partout avec des quartiers blancs et des
quartiers noirs il est donc très facile
pour le parti au pouvoir de rassembler
ou de diviser les communautés de
couleurs afin d'obtenir un avantage
politique maximal
oui le risque corollaire Fanny c'est de
renforcer les extrêmes oui évidemment et
ce qui se passe en noyau c'est que comme
les cartes des circonscriptions ont été
dessinées de façon à ce que les
républicains ne puissent pas perdre la
seule chose dont les candidats
s'inquiètent lors des élections ce sont
les primaires et la seule menace qui
pèse alors sur un candidat républicain
sortant c'est un rival encore plus à
droite or lors des primaires ceux qui
votent sont souvent les électeurs les
plus radicaux et c'est comme ça que sont
élus des candidats extrêmes et que sont
proposés des lois comme la loi sur
l'avortement interdit en noyau à partir
de la détection d'un rythme cardiaque
c'est-à-dire autour de 6 semaines en
fait grâce au gérimentering le Parlement
de Loyau a une super majorité qui lui
permet de rejeter un véto éventuel du
gouverneur ils sont donc tout puissants
correspondante de France 24 aux
États-Unis merci Fanny c'est la fin de
ce magazine merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter sur France 2
[Musique]